That's the only business case that
you can build from Europe that
could be worth a trillion, but not,
honestly, no, not
because we do it, others do it too, not
because we're so cool or so intelligent,
but that's the point  every
other AI game
is decided in the USA or in China
or maybe somehow
Israel as a niche market or
whatever now batteries or
electric vehicles the Chinese and
the Americans who play the game we
can only see what we do
In between, there is a market where
it is different and that is the
electrification of buildings in
mass and scale. There is no
developed market that has more removable
share that is more specifically designed for what
we do, which is the only
reason why Tesla  or or even sunrine
from California has not been dominated for a long time,
the Americans
simply neither have a liberalized
electricity market nor do they have the
penetration of renewable energy, that is,
the only absolute giga mega trend that
exists that
can be decided from Europe is also for a
global game  what we do
welcome to the OMR podcast I
could also say welcome
back to the OMR podcast after 2 years it is
once again an overdue
update about the company
1.5° not only
in Hamburg but here is quite a
huge story one of the few
Billions of companies here in the city
that were built artificially
were founded artificially, so the famous
unicorn, even in Germany there are
n't that many in recent years that have
managed to grow as extremely as
1.5°, as we talked about zi years ago, there
was already one  A bit of the story of the
founder Philip Schröder out in the
background at Sonnen, among others,
in the energy industry and also at
Tesla and then, above all,
now the founder of 1.5°, first of all,
welcome Philip hi, thank you for
allowing me to be back, so that's it  more
than
justified, but before we
get into the whole justification,
maybe once again for everyone who
hasn't heard anything for a long time,
didn't hear the first podcast we did two years ago
in which Nutchell is your big story,
you were once  Tesla Germany boss
exactly yes and you decided D but there is
something else in the world other than
Tesla exactly so yes so it was
definitely so that's definitely one of the
stories that helped
me become better known
but now looking back it's not the one
has the greatest significance for my
personal development but I
was the head of Tesla in Germany for two years
and they were very exciting years
because back then Tesla was still totally
unknown, so here at the hotel
they often asked me if I was
from Tesa  No joke, I work
here in Hamburg too if you
wanted the invoice, that was
before the Model S. Back then there was only the
Roadstar, which was an old Lotus that
had a few Panasonic batteries in it, so that's what it was
really early on and was a very, very
exciting time and also a very
successful time and to this day I have
some people in my environment, even at 1.5°,
some people but also friends
who come from that time,
yes and the story was like that  I
think you were at the event, you
presented at the time and then el
mask saw you there or spoke to you like
that, no, so yes, I have to
tone it down a little bit or let
me let out a little bit of air,
so I was out and about with Sonnen in Silicon
Valley back then  Sonnen was still called
Sonnenbatterie and had just
received its first funding, which at that time
was 3 million euros, which was
a relatively small ticket. Cleantech was
n't that big in 2000 13 either, so there was
n't the
VC yet  Interest and
also the private equity interest that
exists today also because the products
were not yet that advanced and I
actually have Sonnen was one of
the first lithium battery producers
or manufacturers for solar systems, i.e.
private solar systems, and I
have that in Siligon  Valley lectures
were given at the investor roadshow
and somewhere there they must have seen me
or found me because they
then came to me via LinkedIn and the
message that I have in the inbox was on
behalf of Elan mask but it was the team
so and so  was already better known back then
but it was more of a bubble
popularity no one here on the street would have
known who Elan Musk was
in 2013 and then they
approached me and asked if I
wanted to set up the Germany business and
I did that and then  If
you're there, but you can
also listen to the separate
podcast that we did two years ago in detail,
scroll down and then
you won't be there for long, so zi years is
also a long time, but not that
long, so in those were very  A long
two years, yes, it was definitely
exhausting, but it was also really cool,
so looking back, it impressed you,
especially in the one, to
do things that are consistent, so a
bit like that, yes, you just need the
supercharger is the best example  There was
no
charging infrastructure in Germany, zero, so there is
still little today and the motorway is
of course also an international
phenomenon, which means there is
nowhere outside of Germany that
you can drive faster than 120,
which means the roofs went and the
tops went  Not too much from the Model S, the
car also used way too much power, so
you didn't get very
far and since it was really important to Ilan back then
to cut a good figure in Germany against the German
manufacturers, we were
able to try out a lot of things early on, so we
had  the first superchargers we
also opened the first showrooms, which is what
we're doing today at 1.5°, we
went out and then went back
to sunbathe so that's in the end you can
say
solar power company yes so maybe
it's today back then it was actually like
that  The first wave of the solar boom
was over. From 2000 to 2011 there was a
lot of feed-in tariff
from the state if you built a solar system,
so it had little to do with what
we do today and this
feed-in tariff was cut in 2011 by
Philip Rösler, that is what they
said  It's overfinancing and it
made a hard cut back then
the solar industry in Germany
collapsed then there are all
the
pioneering companies, many of them
went bankrupt and that's where the idea came from to
say, well, it's okay somehow  It does
n't make sense to feed in electricity, but
it actually makes sense to use the electricity
that you produce on site directly yourself,
that's called
self-consumption, that's what
almost everyone does today - that's the business case that
we offer today and for that
you need a battery because that's the
problem  The fact is that solar power
is produced when the sun is shining and
when you come home in the evening
the sun often doesn't shine and that's why
a battery was very important for this application.
Using electricity on site yourself was extremely
important and solar power was above all a
battery  a pc batteries yes
lithium iron phosphate batteries that were
placed in a rital sound cabinet
and then inverters were
planted on it and the
excess electricity was stored with it, that's what
we did back then Sonnen was
later sold to Shell and is
perhaps already there today
solar power company I know if you
can say it like that and is your professional life
actually
more or
less irrelevant from an income perspective because you got
so much stock option over the years at Tesla, uh I
don't know,
plus the price development in the last few
years that you somehow  It's
enough now or are you still working
for the money would have had a bicycle chain so
I would have all that so first of all I
left after two years I have a
four year plan at Tesla and it was
pretty good so looking back it was
good anyway but of course you knew that
Back then, I didn't know how great
it would develop and I wasn't that visionary
that I actually
firmly assumed that
Tesla would develop like that,
because there were just so many problems in
day-to-day business that you thought
it couldn't work that way  I
sold all of my shares that were vested immediately
and I now have all my money
back in the company, which means I am
also my own investor, so
I also acted as a normal investor in the rounds of the
Series A seed funding round in
addition to what I
said  I once invested founder shares that I
also have myself, which means
I can say that
95 and more percent of my netwk
are in my company, so
let's get in now, what is
the current value of the company according to the last
round of financing?  According to the last
round of financing Post money no, that's
basically the value after the
financing round we are at
around 950,960 million euros and
at the current rate that's just over a
billion US dollars okay so that means
Unicorn has reached the limit exactly so that
's exactly  It's always a
philosophical debate, yes,
people usually talk about
unicorn status with a dollar billion,
but we are just under the
euro billion and well above it,
depending on what the price is at the moment,
we are over it, but that is also
now  It
's been a while now and a lot has happened since then, so we
've already done the factors, so there
are now statements about
460 million euros in sales in 23 exactly
exactly so we we we actually
had sales growth in the last 24
months and  It's only been
two and a half years, that is, since the
first short year of over 2200%, we have
increased sales to 460 million euros
in
2023 exactly
and how can they
grow so quickly and already make half a million in
sales but still
only double that  The reason for
this is that
your sales are of course very
strongly driven by M&A, so you
buy in and that is of course not as
attractive in terms of the multiplier as
sales are now, which are shooting through the roof organically,
but we'll get to that point  In the
meantime, how much
to say again is the money
you earned, you didn't
take it all as equity, you also
took in loans, so borrowed capital, so up to now we are still on
the deadline today, we are still
debt-free for us, you have it  I have just
mentioned one of the points that
meant a lot of need for financing for us
and also improvement, which is why
the acquisition of additional companies,
which means we are growing in the
workbench, so what we do is
photovoltaic systems, heat pumps, charging
infrastructure, i.e. the
electrification of a home
across Europe as far as Australia  is our
business plan and we are buying a lot of
craft certificates in order to
get to the regions more quickly and for that
we need capital or did we
need a lot of capital and what we
have done now is that we
no longer want to be dependent on it ourselves
the cash portion we
also give options for the purchase price but a
portion is also cash so that we
no longer have to do equity financing for it.
The model is
very scalable and now we have
it so it's not bad to get
bankability after two full financial years
means we are bankable
we got the first the first line
which we are now Zen B gives
you credit normally s doesn't get a
bank loan because all of that
isn't there yet the balance sheets aren't sufficient
Reg want to have three years and
we have after zi years  Still
got something and BMB paribar Deutsche
Bank and LBBW are now,
I would say, rather conservative banks,
which means we have been properly
audited and what we now
want to achieve with this is this
decoupling so that we no
longer have to use equity capital for acquisitions
no more giving away shares to
get new money you can just
take it out and hopefully pay it
back but okay then back to
the business model because we've already
talked a lot about career and especially now about valuation but other
questions okay what exactly is it you  you've
just said, I'll say it with
my words, you have a showroom
here in Hamburg too, in
Jungfernstieg, I'm in a good location,
it's a bit like an Apple look
and feel and you say we
are, so to speak, the Apple
for energy for people  At home i.e.
from the wallbox to the heat pump via
an app like this at the end with which you
can buy your energy and sell it
which you then generate yourself if in doubt
solar modules everything from a single source everything
from you i.e. I don't make any cars yet
but  the interface to Tesla in the z
or to other
electric cars but in the natchell that
is, so to speak, how you
come across, at least to the outside world.
I think there are three innovations behind it,
one of which is the
idea of ​​doing everything on one platform
for both the end customer
Platform as well as for you who now
buy from craft businesses, that they are all
put on one platform, so to speak,
and that you, so to speak, that the same
KPI, the same structure, and the same software are
completely used, that's a
different way of putting it, so to speak, yes,
definitely, um, I can do it
too  still in its own way but
basically it's a good
summary. I think the part
that's still missing is that these
assets will later also be offered in the energy market. So
that means the
paradigm shift with which you
know, most people
simply know photovoltaics and  Solar from
the media and say you can use it
to produce your own electricity and it's
cheaper than from the grid but the
bigger picture is that
everything is actually electrifying, which means
mobility is becoming electric. Heat from
oil and gas goes to a heat pump that
will  also electrified and we see
ourselves as an electrification platform
for your home, which means we want to be able to offer any type of
electrical appliance for
you in the
installation and in the end we want it
but we always call it the
virtual workbench that means behind it
yes  A wide variety of trades,
some of which don't even know each other in today's reality,
that means you have the
municipal utility, they are the operator of the
smart meeter or the
electricity meter, which is still stupid at the moment, then
you have the trade, the electrician who installs
the solar system and  They have the
energy storage then you have the
roofers who put the modules on the
roof then you have the
heating company and they install the
heat pump or your gas term or
whatever and then you have the
mobility, you have an electric car in front of the
door  or so far a combustion engine and
actually all these areas
that merge in the house and we offer
everything you need for CO2 neutral
energy from a buy the product
so if I come to you now and
the normal customer buys what from you,
I say  wants to have everything and then
maybe just takes one part and gets
in first and says I
just want to have the heat pump from you or
how exactly it works but the same is true as
customers usually come and have
an idea like that, some come and say I
Somehow I read in advertising or
somewhere that solar
is really interesting and then they
actually come and say I want to
have a photo bot system but then they go
out and say I actually have to
start with the heat pump. There are some
that do everything that has the highest
take rate  As the saying goes,
at the moment there is a solar system with electricity storage
and the wall box because you can quickly make the
advantage of self-produced ones available
in the house and also for the
electric car because the advantage
is relatively high, i.e. if you have
a photovoltaic system of 1.5°  We
are also the manufacturer of the modules and
also the guarantor. If you
produce electricity on your roof, it is
CO2 neutral and costs an average of 5
cents. We guarantee this to be inflation-free
for 30 years, which means that if you
strap the device onto the roof you come from
a world where you are between 30 in  Hamburg
also pays 35 to 40 cents per
kilowatt hour in a reality where you
only pay 5 cents for at least the electricity produced on the roof.
What percentage of your
electricity can you create if you
live in Hamburg? That's right now
Let's move on to the
second part of the business model. The
bigger your solar system is, the
bigger the problem is that it
only produces electricity for 2000 hours a year,
there are 8700 hours a year,
which means the problem is that you often
produce electricity when you  you're not at home and you do
n't need it at all and
you're often at home or the sun doesn't
shine when you need it and what we
do with the energy management system, which we call harbeat, is that we
make sure that our
own consumption is stored in a battery  is
controlled in such a way that
you actually store the excess electricity
in the electric car,
so you drive off with the heat pump or
then also in the electricity storage system so that
you save in the evening when you turn on the daily news, er
electricity but what in the end
with the storage options that means
from my electricity needs which I like
have as normal 90% is absolutely possible
no if you could with you then
really yes significantly
reduce your electricity by bill or talk absolutely
absolutely I think absolutely
100% you could we have to
first put a point and an exclamation mark
now  But that's what happens when you get
started with electric
heat and electric mobility, your
electricity consumption increases significantly.
That means what you so often
find out is that customers come
to us and get a solar
energy storage system, then the first
electric car comes and then they say
oh my solar system is actually too
small or the second
electric car is coming and then the
heat pump is added, a
German household will
easily triple its electricity consumption no, that means the
system has to grow with it and it is
still important how you
get the remaining electricity  e.g. in winter
when there is no solar period for a long time and
we solve that straight away with okay but let's say
you have
a sufficiently large module and that and you
now have your electricity requirements under
control and now you know electric cars and
all that a little more  than before, yes, then the
savings that
you can create permanently are already
significant, so from 5 cents to
somehow 50 or 45 cents or so, it is
a huge relief for the electricity bill,
but you
probably have one or two times
Acquisition costs for
you, what do I have to put on the table
when I say to you now, okay, I
want to have the sensible
starter package where I can immediately
save money, i.e. the
starter package with a solar system wallbox
and electricity storage where you get exactly this
80% reduction in electricity costs  You also come
straight away and simply use CO2-neutral electricity
at home with all the bells and whistles,
so we also always install a
smart tenant, which is now simply
an intelligent electricity meter that
also makes you fit for the energy market of the
future. Then you'll be at €20,000.
20,000 okay, how many people are already doing this
so in Germany you can
say that around 10% of all
suitable buildings already
have a solar system, but as a rule
either the wallbox is missing, for example,
or there is also a lack of
electricity storage, there are many
solar systems  not have not from us no
no but how many how many times have
you already sold yourself as 20,000€ packages
so we have installed a total of
100,000 energy systems since the company was founded but
all of the
energy systems that we have on offer are included,
so heat pumps, power storage and
also photovoltaic systems, some of them  So
the number of customers is less because
you are less precise. I would say in
Germany last year we
served around 25,000 customers in 23.
Okay, but these are
permanent customers, so they stay with us for
several years or decades
you because they spent so much money
and now I want to say that it
somehow lives and
now okay okay that means it's a
big shopping cart yes probably but it's
also not easy to acquire customers for it
because you have to explain a lot first
you have to show the advantages
You probably also have to
build up trust that people are now
having your things installed in their house, where do
you get these customers from, so how do
you manage to get them? Do
you somehow switch to
Verox and Check 24
and then you want to have cheap electricity tariffs?  I have it
then I'm amazed at what I have to do for it
or how does it work so we're not at Vero
and at the moment it's also the case
that
we usually have more requests
than we can process because I
already had them before  Let's just say there is
this virtual assembly line, we
do everything in the final process ourselves,
that means our craftsmen are
our vehicles are our
systems that are shipped there we
have to install the Smart meeter that is
the intelligent electricity meter we have to
install the energy management system
that means  In the end,
we install
a reusable IOT platform in every building to
which we
can later connect a heat pump and
other systems that are then all connected to
the electricity market and
we still have a so-called
bottleneck in the capacity that we can
It's actually been implemented,
which means that at the moment it's more like
we have too many customers and
how come to you? I mean,
we now have a relatively large amount of PR
that's happening and of course you also have to
think about the addressable market
we alone have  We are already in seven markets in six
markets.
In Germany alone we have a potential of
around 20 million
homeowners
or small commercial properties.
Across Europe there are 75 to 80 million
suitable buildings. We are
number 3 in Sweden in terms of supply, so we are in
third place  just say open the door, make
the offer available, get
listed somewhere PR we do PR we also
have of course we also do
a lot on social media so we also try to
provide information about
our tariffs and also about CO2
neutral living, we also do advertising
but  If you
compare it with e.g. pire or
other competitors, it's a nonsense
and it actually comes from the fact that
we get quite a lot of references
and also have a high unique position,
which means we just do
n't stop there  Hardware, that means
for us it's not just about solar systems
but, just as you say, the customer
is advised by us holistically and
then served holistically and we
currently have the problem of being
able to really meet customer demand, especially if a customer
wants the entire package  In the area of ​​just
photovoltaics and electricity storage it's
fine, that's fine because you're
just saying P yourself, Mario Kohl,
the founder, was already
a company here that is associated with similar topics,
but there's a leasing
business so the customer reads it
Devices and they are now not
connected in the way you just
described it, the difference is
mainly between you and I would say
P is mainly because they
have dealt with it,
okay, so how can I now  There are
a lot of people who want to have solar, there are a
lot of people who also want to have heat pumps
and I think npal's DNA is
more concerned with saying how can
I represent this initial investment through a
rental, so then you're
not the owner of the systems, you're
renting  The over 20 years of npal are
comparable to what
leasing companies are like and we
focus much more on the
process and also the innovation of
networking, which means we have
all the craftsmanship in-house,
we have built all the software ourselves
that you need from planning because  there are
interpendences between a
heat pump if I have a large
heat pump I need another
solar system if I have two if I
have two charge points I
may also have other
requirements that need to be planned, which
means that from the start we have, above all,
each other  focused on saying what
software do we have to build to
bring the costs down 50% of the costs
are laboratory and we want to
save 50% of the laboratory costs that is only possible
if you ultimately have everything in one hand,
that means we are a process and
production company and  Then when the
assets are installed, we are
primarily a software company that
integrates these assets into the energy market, which
means we don't want to be asset owners,
we want to be asset managers
and we would like to take care of your systems with you
for the next 10 to 20 years
that they
are optimally integrated in the energy market but your sales
now are essentially sold of the
hardware, so that means that say
20,000 customers who have
somehow bought the hardware buy exactly
25,000 customers but exactly so in the end
we are pretty similar to Apple  no,
because for us the flagship is
of course the hardware sales.
That's why we also invest in the product
itself. We are manufacturers of
our own modules, but we
also have suppliers from all over the world to
build a complete product
Customer, yes on our operating
system there is of course an app
infrastructure. You can book software updates
via the app, but you can also
schedule the electrician via the
app, which means we also have a
subscription value that sits behind the one in
hardware sales. Don't
forget we are  two and a half years old
and that's why the absolute Lion
share is currently in the revenue is still
hardware sales but a big focus for
us in the next two years is to
increase the recurring software sales when you
say you produce these things in
Germany  The hardware is
partly in Germany, the normal
producer of such things has them made in China or
we use all of them,
that is, we have suppliers
from the Siligan Valley, we have
suppliers from Germany,
but we also have suppliers from China.
Your hardware is significantly more expensive  as the
SAG from competitors of NP e.g. no
I wouldn't say I would say
app is more expensive so yes I think what
we do is we have
other products I'll give you an
example now we're a bit teacky
but I'll forgive it  As an example,
we work with microinverters,
so if you imagine a solar module that looks
like a
window frame, there is a solar module in it
that produces electricity, but it always has to be
converted into alternating current using an inverter and the problem is that
cheap inverters are
string inverters  They take all the
modules into a so-called string so
that's how they all run through an
inverter. We work with
microinverters and these microinverters
that sit on top of each module. That's more
expensive but has a higher
output, why every module is
controlled when you have a cloud  If you have one
that goes over it or
you have shading from the tree, then a string
inverter is always more inefficient, which
means that the products we offer
have added value, they are
cheaper in output, so that means the
kilowatt hour, so we produce
energy cheaper than our
competitors  The initial costs are
usually a little higher, which means it's
true that we are
higher when purchasing it, but in terms of the effective
electricity price we are by far the cheapest.
But that's technology
and I think that's why we talk a
lot about it with customers
say okay it's not that important
from our point of view whether you pay 10% or more
or less for the
upfront system there is for of course it's
important for many people but the
more important thing for us is to give the customer a
guarantee about the actual
output  If you wanted to buy a diesel generator,
it would also be important for you
whether the manufacturer
guarantees that it will work for 10
years for 20 years
and, secondly, that the
effective electricity price will be given to you at the end. The
generator you work with is also
guaranteed  And that's what we do, although the
guarantee is only worth as much
as the company itself.
You're still a very young company, you're
already bankable, you said, but
when I look at it from 20
years ago when we spoke, it still feels like it
Somehow I think it was just
the Greens who
came into the government who came to the traffic lights because
the interest rates were extremely low and
the whole topic of everyone
needs an advertising pump now had
a completely different one  Another dynamic
than currently felt and I had the
feeling that, okay, the topic had been hit really hard
and it was running up completely
and going through the roof and now
interest rates have, as I said,
the development that we have experienced,
that's what I felt like  not quite as
hot anymore and I also have more
resistance now or am I definitely
100 percent no so because I
think you have so I'll say it's
about a 180° turn in the
macroeconomics no so you have exactly what
you say so  It felt like it was the same
two years ago you thought okay the
politicians are so behind it um there is
such broad support from
the population too um the name law
has that or let me say not the
name law per se but the
dispute over the
name law has that  totally politicized, it's a
shame and totally counterproductive,
that means the good news is that everyone
has an opinion about a
heat pump, the bad news is that it's
also a
scapegoat for many issues, that is, you
simply have political camps
that have already formed  That's annoying
because it's simply because you can't talk about
the technology like that
and about the advantages,
but it's very quickly
polemicized and ideology
and the other things you've already
mentioned, the electricity prices are
down again, which basically means there's this
panic  from two years ago
is gone, but we think that's a good thing because it
also consolidates the market again and
because customers are
paying more attention again and we believe that we can
meet the requirement better
than others. Part of our
business strategy is consolidation
So we assume that the market
is consolidating and we are a
consolidator, so we also take over
companies, so the
consolidation isn't bad for us,
but high interest rates, low electricity prices and
a policy that also has other problems -
these are certainly things that make it
more difficult  I
would personally say that the macro drivers
are identical and they have
n't slowed down at all, so you
have to think about it: we are also active in Spain,
as we know, there is more sun,
we guarantee inflation-free
electricity prices of 2 cents over 30 years,
CO2 neutral, the good thing  The news is that
we also say, for example, that
we are committed to ensuring that our industry
receives less subsidies, so we
notice that this has also
become a media plaything, something
isn't working and the
renewables industry in particular often comes
and says  Okay, now we need more
money as it just felt like everyone is
doing no and um I would
say that in the short term I think 24 25
really won't be easy because there are just so
many so many um also headwins
for the first time but in the long term
from my point of view it remains that  The topic is completely
intact, we have been able to reduce the costs for our
customers by 40%
within a year. Electricity costs yes, yes,
that also means both the
entry costs and that correlate
but also the effective ones, so our
product has
become significantly more competitive, which also means that  It has
to do with the fact that the supply chains
have relaxed, that there has been more
competition, so in this respect
I would say the best is J to come
but 24 itself will be a
year of detoxification in the industry, that's just the way it is, the
industry has received a lot of money, the
industry has a simple one  Growth behind
you and that's now
over, I remember a little bit, that's a
completely different area, but you have to
know that I heard it
from you in your other conversation. You've
already made 8 takeovers in the last two and a half years,
all of them from craft businesses  Buying together, there's a
bit of that
in the Amazon area, there was also
trasio and the various clones, we
also had some people here on the podcast as
guests who then also this
trasio we buy up various Amazon
dealers, smaller companies and bring
them to a new platform  That's
now with the interest rates where it's become really difficult
to finance all these purchases to raise capital for it
has
now really hit the wall really hard,
um and
that's nothing now so a
little bit of this woman so there's
now someone who  is a crazy
fundraiser who then
somehow buys companies
together so that you can, yes, but
you can, so
we can see that if you look
at Berlin or you look at
the European venture capital market, that's what
flows there  Blood in the streets
right now that means the person lets
people so I pretend no matter who the
company you are talking about you
just notice the reviews are under pressure
and so on I would now
do our case once and also very
calmly you have that forin  I already
said Philip a billion, no, you
already have super high sales, we
are profitable, we also tackle hardcore,
so we are really into tackling, but we are
still profitable and decent, so we
win almost 50 million euros, um that means we have
several advantages, firstly ours
I said at the beginning that we are paying for acquisitions, so far
we are debt-free. That has
been really important until now because the
companies you talked about
have the problem. They
went into their fundraising or
their business with the assumption that
the interest would be theirs  no idea 4 5 6%
costs and now they cost them 14 yes
because they might also
need venture capital so venture dead
that's we worked without dead that's a bit stupid on the equity side
because you're wasting away
but we're debt-free that  means we are we are
from these we are
not have several transport dependencies we
have not built ourselves a model where we are
dependent on very low interest rates offered we are cash low positive
and profitable we have to do it we do
n't dream of it and or want to
go there at some point  We earn
a lot of money because the business model
also has a golden
foundation and we are simply
better at what we do. And the
last point is that we
received our ratings in one of the
worst environments that has ever
existed in recent years  That means we
also have a different driving dependency,
not many companies se what the
unicorn zombies or there are already some
abbreviations that correct, yes, they
are still on paper Unicorns
but today they would never ever
get this rating we have in
this one  Environment our first fundraising
started right in the slowdown and
then also in a very bad
environment, i.e. in a problematic environment and I
'm also super relaxed about it because it's
very, very important that you as a
shareholder or as a founder don't
fight against a market environment where
your existing ones actually exist
Investors have invested on a sales multiple of
still a out of 21 yes or
you haven't got E yet, which means we
don't have the risk that other
companies have that were previously funded and
had significantly higher valuations that had significantly different discounted
cashfow models that never
got bankability  and in that respect
I would also turn it around for
us. We are in a position where we
are debt-free. We are in a
position where we have strong investors.
We are in a position where we
are cashow positive. I think we have high liquidity levels and
I have respect for that  mus
I'm beindr V Z you also
said to me two years ago Philip our
plans are for 23, I think you've
planned to reach 500 million euros in sales at the time I thought okay,
very brave and then in the end it turned
out to be 460, I think that's fair enough  that
we would have done 500,
the goal was also good, but still, I'm
already talking about really, that's a
world-class level, to be able to
put things together so quickly, and you've
more or less
delivered, what is the
goal now if you say  the next two
ahead so sales billion is in sight
the sales billion is in sight but
what is much more important for us are
a few qualitative characteristics so
one is that
we are now better known
for selling solar systems and
heat pumps  So you can
go to our website, get it built,
have an app, everything is fine,
what happened in the background,
I also sent you the app,
which is that we
have built a marketplace in the
meantime
Available for half a year, that means that
even if you don't have a solar system,
our motto is yes to live and wind
in sunlight forever for free so this
myth comes, let's just
align all electrical consumers with sun and
wind because whenever there is a lot  There is sun and a lot of
wind, the price of electricity has
been proven to be very low,
sometimes negative and the electricity is CO2
free, that is our mission, that is the
vision that we are working on and this
Mark has to make it very clear that it
is a monster monster vision
because we  In Germany
we always have this topic, we are still founding the
20th e-commerce startup and somehow
socks and sweets and some
better drinks
so you have a really
big vision so really copied the WS
somehow think a little bigger
and say so we want
people  We
can get energy from the sun and wind completely free of charge and
we do all of that. Well, it's
a relatively logical conclusion.
I always feel like someone who, imagine
you're 1998, someone who
understands the Internet and then
you try a VC or podcast  To
explain to the host why it is a good idea
to sell shoes online and not at
Mays, I don't know what we have discovered
for us and that is also
physically unavoidable. We are building a
system that
has to build up huge excess capacities that we can
then store or smooth out somehow  That means
we build solar systems,
we build wind systems, we
already have such great volatility in the system
that the network or
consumption is not even able
to absorb these quantities,
wind turbines are switched off and so
on, which means the energy market is
changing  from centralized
production that follows the consumer,
i.e. the power plants start up when we get
up in the morning and the power plants
go down in the evening when production
slows down to
a decentralized generation of
wind onshore offshore solar systems on
millions of house roofs large
open spaces regardless of where the
consumption occurs  This means that
consumption must follow the volatile
power sources and no longer
the production of the central consumer
and that sounds easy
but it is a huge paradigm.
Batteries need above all
intelligent electricity meters. It is very
simple, you have a price signal and  The
price signal tells you, Philip,
you can charge your electric car tonight
for 10% of the price as tomorrow at lunchtime.
Now it's completely clear Denmark
Sweden Finland, they've been running on this system for a long time.
The
smart meters are now coming in and that makes
total sense because if  If you now
had software that simply knows
what the prices are a day in advance because you
can pre-cast the production well then
your car would pre-cast the production is called
weather reportk no that means
the software does it by itself but yes it does  The
software chews on the weather data. There
are already very valid models that predict wind
and sun very, very validly over 24 to 48
hours and then
the price on the electricity market is fixed a day
in advance, which means we know with
100% probability
what your electricity price will be
at night and when it is particularly
low, our software ensures
that your car does not charge when the
electricity price is high, but rather when it is
low. What percentage of
a country's electricity consumption is B2C
and how much is B2B, so what what what
can  Consumers
in general are aimed primarily at the B2C sector because they
have an influence on how much the
industry takes. You can roughly
assume that it's a question of how
you calculate it, but if you have
private mobility and private
heat and private
electricity consumption  which already exists today, if you
combine it and electrify it, that
's at least two thirds, because
you can't forget that's
what many people always forget. You
electrify the entire
energy output that we
have in mobility today with diesel and gasoline and you
electrify it all  Oil and
gas power that we use today to
heat every house with a gas boiler or oil boiler and also every
block of flats and that's a huge
second, okay, the two thirds are then,
so to speak, in a country like
Germany, in the end we are
private users with our needs
and only one and a third is the industry
with its production, so I'm
not 100% sure now, but in terms
of the size order, that could
fit, but it doesn't matter for
the simple reason that the paradigms
are the same,
I always say that  We have
a partner who invested with us early on,
that's
Mr. Wacker and Mr. Wacker said to me
yes exactly and Mr. Wacker
said to me at some point I told him
what we were doing here and why we
believe that the hardware and  the
electricians are just the first step
and the second step is that you
just find a marketplace where you can then
activate consumers, i.e.
charge an electric car or run a heat pump
if the price is low and he
looked at me like you do now because
he doesn't have one  Understood the word and
at some point he said to Mr. Schröder that they
mean load shedding like that and um the
industry has been doing it for a long time in other
words that means the industry has
long been at the stromwörfe the industry
knows the principles that when the
price of electricity goes up um there is
also load shedding  and that means in
the end we don't do anything other
than a system that
has only one dimension, is totally non-dynamic, is
totally inflexible, we have
electricity meters that are only read manually once a year,
of course
we can't follow price signals
everything we do  Now what we do is we
follow the law of supply and
demand and that is the platform that
we build for it and the solar system or
the heat pump is only one player in
there. The heat pump
always wants to have the cheapest electricity,
regardless of whether it comes from your solar system  comes from
or from the strombse I've heard it
's somehow already in Scandinavia,
where people are even more aware of it
across the board or it's
mainly because
people are aware of it across the board because
partly in the weather report in the
or in the  TV then they don't just
say tomorrow it's somehow 23° and
sunny, but tomorrow it's 23° sunny and
the electricity costs 30 or 20 C, exactly in
Denmark that's the case and also in
Sweden and in Sweden
we're very good at it  I mean, what you're
doing is what we need as a
society.
Bra, if you go to Aid and say without a
label, what do you want, just say that
I think that would
be mega genre marketing? W the price of electricity
on television, but you know what's already
happening  I showed you the app,
so our customers who
suddenly check that they know through our
marketplace a day in advance if
I charge my car now and then and do it
automatically via our
systems, then they get money for it instead of
me paying for it
We already have this effect because we have total
heavy users who look at this
electricity price curve all day long and yes
we can also ask the day look
but the important point is in
Germany can in this in this
realm in this whole  Universe that
we're talking about right now only the immersion
that has a smart meter and in
Germany 99% of everyone has a
smart meter 99% of all
meter points are still old meters that
means that's why I'm here but you do
n't just need a smart meter
you need  Yes, also in your house where
you have solar modules on it, yes, but
I think the crucial thing is that you
don't necessarily need the solar module for our concept. We
would always say that if you have a solar system if you
have your own roof, get a
solar system because you have over 30 years
inflation-free at 5 cents CO2 neutral
SPR you can't use the roof
properly and if you live in the apartment
or you say you also have a
can also so you can have a fat
apartment or an unsuitable roof
you can still get a smart tenant with us
Get your heat pump based on the
electricity market and
benefit from the fact that the price of wind power
is still low, okay, but then
you don't sell on the electricity you produce yourself,
but then that means you
can never make money, but you can
at least get it cheaper right and you
can also get some of the
negative in this  During electricity price phases,
you also get money for
purchasing electricity because it's something really
really so you can also you can
again because then you don't
have to store it and then you're happy if
you do. Now let's get back to the
fundamental foundation of our
business theory
So what's happening right now
is the wind turbines are switched off at
night when there's too much wind
and the negative electricity prices
only arise because they can't
switch them off quickly enough. I
mean, who wants to produce electricity
and have to pay money for
producing it?  I mean, you
probably know that if you drive overland yourself,
you'll see wind farms from time to time that
are standing still and the wind is blowing, they
're shut down and why because
we can't manage to transport this electricity away
to regions that still
have consumption, but if so  The whole of Hamburg
charges its electric cars whenever
the wind blows then BU you don't need
to transport anything then you use the
network that is there but it's not
a question of blatant ones that have to be laid
no because it's just a
shift in the load  so cool
that it's so hard to explain
it's all about everyone coming
home and charging electric cars so yes
and the same thing with the heat pump
you currently have a heat pump that
just always turns on when the
temperature filler says I need it now
Heat and then it goes off completely
regardless of whether there is wind
or not, you could also wait 5 hours,
the water still has better
and the buffer storage still has
heat. This is the
dimension of the price of the orientation
of one of them  Operation of the heat pump
from the operation of the air conditioning we
are also traveling in Australia from
the operation of the charging of the
electric car or the electricity storage
according to a price point on the stromark what you
just described
is already somewhere very
understandable now somewhere
perhaps still a bit
revolutionary a huge one  Problem
at least in Germany where I
can observe this. I would also say that
most people I know
have the electricity and IT checked once a year
and yet it would
probably be much better and
better on a variety of levels if it
were different and more dynamic  would be and so
um you are the only ones who approach the topic
in this form now how many how
many companies are there a lot
more people have to work mus exactly what
you can distinguish is you have
companies like npal or something like that you
know them  or you put them in competition with us
because we also sell solar systems, but
then you have
companies like Octopus or tibba tibba
is better known, come from Sweden, and they
offer dynamic electricity tariffs, which
means you don't get the
typical flat rate you just pay  35 cents
no matter when that's what we
know in Germany or then you go
to Z verox and then someone
doesn't give you 35 cents but 34 cents and then
you give an eco-tariff because it's
certified and then you feel good
but they just stop  They say, come on,
let's negotiate you through the electricity market
and give you direct access to the
electricity market and make it more flexible, go by
prices, okay, different
problem yourself, different type of solution, okay, exactly
and what we're doing now is we're
simply bringing these two worlds
together  That is, we say, what's the point
if I hang my
static consumption on one of the
electricity exchanges? I can, I do
n't want to turn off the TV just
because the price of electricity is high at the moment and
I don't want the electric car
not to be charged because of that  and what
we do is we link it up,
we only install systems, i.e. only
heat pump charging infrastructure,
we can switch all the systems we install
ourselves via our interfaces,
which means we can first of all
make sure that you always use your solar power,
but when we install the smartmer we
look at it  We also look for
the price signal and say aha, look,
dear Philip,
the electricity price will be 2 cents on the
electricity exchange tomorrow night and then we'll fill up the
electric car, we'll fill up
your electricity storage, we'll
let your heat pump run and
that  Let's do something together because
the classic energy suppliers, I
mean, they all want to do the same thing,
so if that's a revolution, I think it's a
revolution that
hasn't caught the eye of venture capital or the OMR community yet, but that's
the end  the holy grail that everyone is
working on Tesla energy is working on it
you want to sell the asset at the end
and then you want to manage it for life that
's what you
want to do so like with the cell phone you
also want to sell the cell phone and
then you want that  It's
best for the customer to use your software over the next 20 years,
so there's already
a huge battle to get the
assets into the households
and then manage them. In the
end, I could now
also order systems from Wattenfall
not because it's a waste,
I think it's a bad comparison because
the problem is that you
have to make the forecast very well and
you have to be able to control these systems yourself,
which means that if you
just offer the tariff, it does
n't help at first  The tariff provider must
also be able to control at the same time
and that makes waiting and the
big ones don't do that because it's
not their game. Neither can they, the
decentralized ess li Lichtblick is a
good example, they can do that too.
Lichtblick has the ambition to be able to do that
and they certainly come
into the topic with more knowledge than
many other large providers. Yes, there
are different ones. I've
already given it in the podcast here as a
reference,
as well as places that
offer something like that, I mean Schü Kopf no no no
yes so basically  you have to be able to do
a lot of things in parallel you
have to once or even an Eon could
ne so Eon is also B a huge
company listed on the stock exchanges extremely large
extremely worth a lot so or even an
Octopus they have just raised 800 million
ne s US sch a UK based  energy
companies that are more from the
energy supply sector but
what you had to be able to do in the new world
you have to install both the
IT infrastructure on the customer because you
first have to upgrade the house
so that all systems are ultimately
connected to the Internet and all systems are also balanced at the end
because you end up buying
for each system, so that
's cumulative per customer, but you
first have to upgrade the house,
so we need a smart meter that's on the
internet, we have an energy management
system that's also posted on the internet,
the energy management system takes effect
on all the consumers
you have and ideally you now have to be able to do
the volulfilmment
craft and also be able to sell the
hardware because that's where
the big margin is right now, you
make the money in the hardware business, that's
why there are many hardware
companies  You can obviously see that
apart from the rent, npal is,
first of all, a hardware canie, we
also have a sola, exactly yes
and then you have but behind it for the
lifetime value it
is really important to say because
who delivers the software  in
and that's the reason why
the municipal utilities are also difficult because you
not only have to be able to do energy trading so you can
somehow buy for
these customers, but of
course you also have to develop the software
and that's pretty difficult to be
able to do all three at the same time
to build the software that you need
for energy management and for this
for the virtual power plant in it you have to
be world class because that is really
the scalable one then you have to be extremely good
at selling a lot of hardware because the
manufacturers will
only submit to your platform the manufacturers  Those who
make the hardware only open the
interfaces for you if you have a large quantity.
That's a bit like how it took a
long time until you had Google AirPlay in
the big OEMs because of course
the OEMs in the automotive sector said
we don't want that, no, that means
you  you have to have a lot of hardware sales you have to
have vertical integration which is
the best example of this in the end
Tesla Tesla energy are the ones who, in
my opinion, do the cleanest thing together with Octopus,
they have the
installation under control themselves they have
complete vertical integration hey I
could do anything  If you offer them, I could
now also
buy a heat pump and something like that from Tesla, yes, if
so, you can certainly
see Tesla as a player like that if you
live in Australia, California or Texas,
they have this intersection of their
own hardware installation and the
software segment  In all other
markets, even Tesla is not yet
active, especially in Europe, not
at that time, somehow this sola city was
bought from Elon Musk's cousins ​​or something to do exactly that,
but that was already in
2000 14 that I bought Solar City
for a very long time, yes, exactly, but that
's a, I think that
nothing will happen for a long time because they
have first prioritized the vehicles, but those are
the ones that, in my opinion, are the
cleanest, but it does
n't seem like a winner teax  to be allmk
so when there are now so many players
from different corners so they say
the
experienced energy companies and then
somehow
hardware more then the Tesla there is
felt like there are so if you
just look at the hardware market it's
all very winnerteex  difficult because you
have 27 countries in Europe alone,
all of which have other regularly regulated
energy markets, which means you also have
very different hardware players that
are in there, which means you can also see that
in the total numbers, so an
npal or we are on that  overall
addressable market in Europe
Fly [ __ ] still that means so
this winnerts at all only in the
hardware sector is very difficult and
if then if then over decades no so
Tesla is not a winner yet no so
in the car fashion too no
so and that and  Nevertheless, they are
worth trillions, no, in that
one is the second, but there are
segments that you can scale, that is,
for example, what we do is we have
14 manufacturers on our software
platform and what we are now starting to
plan for the end of 24 is that  You can retrofit our
energy management setup with the
intelligent meter,
which means you can buy a system compatible with us from npal or
from any tradesman,
a
heat pump from STIEBEL ELTRON or an
air conditioning system from dken, which the largest
heat pump and LC manufacturer in the world
has  In Europe alone everywhere they
are compatible exactly and then
you can simply then that means we can that is that that is
the
energy management system that we can
decouple that means that the customer can then
say oh I bought the water pump
from Fritze Elektro and buy it
Then at 1.5° I just have the
energy management system where the app is
attached, the whole software backend
and the last point that we
can and want to scale out is the
dynamic tariff, so you simply
get the dynamic tariff as an additional entry point, that means you
You can say you know what I think 1.5°
cool I take the dynamic tariff we
have the cheapest basic fee but
we can't optimize the tariff
unless you buy the
energy management system and of course
we try to coordinate it so
that there are actually three of us
You have entry points, you don't have to buy an electricity tariff from us
in 25 24,
um, and then you see in
your app, wow, I could actually
optimize it a lot, but buy the
energy management system that's compatible with it,
or you just get in via the
energy management system because you
first of all have one  You already have a solar system
and a heat pump and it's
annoying that the heat pump is constantly
drawing power from the mains because it does
n't give a [ __ ] that the solar system is
producing and feeding in, which means
you would like to
have a compatible energy management system or you
can get in directly through hardware sales at the
moment  Our problem is that we
get into it by selling hardware and we
first have to explain these two other elements to people, at least
earn the best money with them, of course,
and of course we want to
continue to do that, which means you will
now have 2 million
solar systems in Germany  There are still a little
more than or just under millions without
electricity storage, these are the older
solar systems, they will all
fall out of the statutory subsidy, which
means that so far they are getting money for
feeding into the grid and when
this subsidy is over, they will
all need electricity storage and  They will
all probably use electric cars
too, that means you have you have that
all want new potential customers for you
and that's
also what I meant you have the
initial question was Philip what are the
goals for so in  the future no and I
said the qualitative characteristics
are more important for us, that means yes we
want to continue selling hardware
next year at least 700 to 750
million euros in hardware sales
but in the background the take rate is
currently rising from the energy management
system of the harbeat platform  100%
that means every customer in seven
markets so the distance between
our northernmost branch and the
southernmost is 20,000 km always gets
this IOT setup and then we decouple
that means the addressable market for the
energy management system is all
compatible systems from dikin that is
one  a few hundred million and the
addressable market for the electricity tariff
to get into our ecosystem are
all electricity customers in Europe, for example,
okay okay, but now the current
turnover of 750 million in hardware is
not bad, that's what makes it, that
's by the way  sorry, that's
already planned for this year, almost a
double-digit million amount just from
software, which means the customers are
already paying for energy trader, that
's the software,
so we already have
millions in sales in the software area
via our software connection, but
I'm selling it  My that means the
hardware you bring it
home so you the Heß order it online
basically there are a
few showrooms so how much is there in
Hamburg is there more yes there
is more there is um should
go through them all so there is  There are still exactly
10 20 showrooms, there will be
a few more that will open up in Berlin
and Munich, these are the flagshipips,
but there are also in the
commercial areas of cities we
now have 72 locations and
every second one will have a showroom
But these are smaller ones that are in the commercial area
that they are selling, but I mean
in the end it's also yours that
all these craftsmen have now bought
38 companies that can then somehow
install all the stuff because it's
clear that's our et hopefully
that we that we, um, that we have
bought companies that we
have made significantly more profitable, that we have
made significantly more powerful, that
now have lower license costs because
we are pumping out third-party software that makes your daily routine more efficient with
the software that you use,
which
means you have a lower  laborcost
that's hopefully what we
can show. In addition, you have an
additional joint procurement, which
means that purchasing is being bundled by
more and more companies and, to be fair, it
has to be said that last year only
about 20% of our growth came
from acquisitions, 80% was already organic
That means we'll just open up new
locations ourselves, so we'll
probably
open 24 locations in Germany alone where
we won't be making any more acquisitions because we've
had the know-how for a long time, so yes,
we have. We think it's good that we're
making acquisitions  we like a PE in the
end like a private equity player
can say EBIT goes up why our
procurement is better than their costs
go down why we throw out the
licenses take out our own
staff are more efficient in use we
have better access to staff we have
a better brand we have  B better
unique position in hardware sales
but what kind of
craft businesses are they then they
were all quite small at the beginning
so an example that I can give from the
beginning when we started was for example
in Götting we
took over a business that  had almost 4 million
euros in sales Ingo and Alex two so Ingo
is a master electrician and Alex was the
commercial manager and they are now
making 25 million euros in sales this year
and have 120 employees. In
fact, we are now taking over
larger companies but we are talking about
electricians  was an
example at the lower end, now we
just took over S in Holland in December,
so we
entered the Dutch market, which is also the reason
why we are making acquisitions in order to be able to
quickly enter the hardware business profitably,
not to
have these greenfield risks, but to be
able to reinz directly  We're looking at
procurement first, we're looking at the
system landscape, going in
sonderosam makes almost 40 million euros in
sales, so it's already bigger than 100%, yes, and
then they're involved back, right,
and that's the reason why you
recently said you want to go
public soon  That's the reason
because we bought Sonam or
because the people are all involved
and you want to get something out of their
participation.
I think it's very clear,
so it's secondary now the motive
for the entrepreneurs who are part of the
group  I think that,
especially in this market environment, they take on
the risks but of course also the
return participation for this, which means they
get shares rich. They are only
successful when we
are successful in the
exit and also have no real
shares, which means they have none
Some kind of voting rights or something, but they
have an economic
return and this is measured
by their own success over the next
few years, which means that the more successful the
entrepreneur is in the group, the
more Shar he gets and the higher the
multiple afterwards, but there is also
one  a few knockouts to protect us,
the more he participates in years, that's
why of course we would
all like to do an IPO but h
also my NS to reveal where
communicated that this should somehow happen in 25
ne so we are relatively
transparent as a company that means we
have
For us, the IPO is the
ideal scenario because we want
customers to be able to become shareholders
because we have noticed that shares
behind 1.5° are one of the most
sought-after topics and our customers are
also keen  have share to Google Suggest
if you come immediately share yes exactly but
you also have many who really ask
because our customers understand the
most what we do and they say how cool
is that because you are building a marketplace an
alternative marketplace that addresses the problems
of the energy transition  solves you no
longer need a redundant fossil system
you are super cool in terms of the brand in terms of
purpose I would like to be a shareholder
and of course we also want
our entrepreneurs to get their cash out
by the way so do we and
our investors too so that means 25 is
then  It's kind of a topic if that's if
it's a we're working towards the
goal, but you know from
the experience of probably everyone's
podcast and life experience that
depends on the capital market environment that
depends on our qualitative and also
our quantitative goals but
if  everything is going as we
imagine it and what we are planning on
then we would like to go to 2 in Germany
or the USA, um that's not completely
certain yet but there is a slight preference
towards nasc, so we are already switching to
ifis accounting and so on  yes,
so to speak, an expectation from you if
you say we would do an IPO
then for a billion valuation
we have just g don't do it we are
already talking about 3 4 5 billion valuations
that you would then expect on the
stock exchange I wouldn't comment on that now
because that  It would simply be dubious,
I don't know what, so we have
expectations that I wouldn't
say here, but they are of course higher than
the current valuation and it also depends on
what we can show by then, um
and the IPO should bring us funds
that will also allow us to do
this  Plan to continue working because what
we notice is when we are allowed to do this for 10 years
with the teams that we
have in the positioning that we have,
the pure
energy suppliers who lose against us, they
don't have the shopping cart, they don't have
the big margin, not the pure solar
companies  Somehow they come from the
trades or from me they also
got venture capital, they do
n't have the deep integration, so they
can't grow inorganically
like us because they don't have the two picture,
they're not multimarket, they do
n't have the procurement bundling skills, which means we have
We've created a starting position for ourselves
where it's going to be quite difficult,
um, for any competitor and
npal, what does it want now, npal is, for example,
Germany only, um, PAL has taken in 2.2
billion
of which, somehow, almost
1.8 billion are FK, which means they're
easy  They already have very high
financial liabilities because they
are a bank and a prop deck. They
have not yet shown that they
can internationalize, um, they
have just sold their rental business
just because I forgot to
ask how much money have you already
borrowed so far we have 340 million
I would
say that it's not
necessarily efficient so far, but it can be
done much better. As a rule, you also look at what
cash you have in the bank. Are you
in debt? And then you'll have to pay
your normal so we are significantly
leaner than everything that
is on the European market with 340 you
now have a billion so money
for three times say
okay so yes vi not enough ne but be
the valuation h but still so you
look at capital efficiency how much
sales  you got it from have to
Hal look look at no so we
've been on the road for two and a half years P
has been on the road for 8 years we have
we've been profitable since the beginning so
even if you calculate profit against it you
have also can yes can yes look
can EBIT the  equity race to EBIT
ratio the equity race to revenue ratio
we are very good everywhere, we clearly say
we have different business, yes I do too,
so I think Mario and I and
alsopal and we are out of
the discussion about who
is better  we are different no, so we
just have we we have different approaches no,
but I still believe that if you are an
investor, a
multinational, if you
want to have a brand that represents the potential for you
in all developed
European markets then there is  This
brand
isn't PAL, it's not because it's only
in Germany until long ago, that means
if you look who has proven that it's
profitable, I mean in addition to the
2200% growth that we achieved,
we also launched six new market entries  at
the same time and
that's why I would say that we
can show that we can show in several
markets in parallel
and just around the stock market topic from what
can the
company like what percentage do
we hold as founders, we are
four founders and we  We have pooled our shares
in one vehicle. I think you can
also read everything about how
much who holds the 40% and that's
about 40% and yes, comparable
stories are not often the case, so if
you look at Zelando they are of
course still there  worth a little more
but I think the founders were
no longer so
heavily involved at that time or at the tark
he also once said that
they were once worth more
but I think his
sheres were also smaller,
I also mean at
npal I would be surprised if Mario
now
asks the question but I don't know it by heart but there
is no car 1 was
such an example. The founders
still owned a lot of shares at the wedding
but it's not that easy
To keep 20%
now that so much money
has already flowed in. Respect, yes, exactly,
I think that's it, I'm happy
about that, but I don't think that's
really the case for us. I'm
not that short-sighted, I think
that  if we do what we
set out to do and that is
this we call it a master plan in three
stages yes and the first stage is this
consolidation of companies purchasing
power bringing in brand bringing in everything
on one app so the second stage is
then this virtual assembly line  to
really show that
50% of the costs that everyone
incurs in the hardware business are
personnel costs because you need them, if
you can do them better than everyone in the
market then you simply have an
incredible one, it's quite clear if we  If we
can optimize 50% then
we are talking about the fact that our large margin
is now at 35 plus%, that we
can improve it significantly even
against the market and when you then
get to the point where you build a marketplace where
the assets that you
buy are all cheaper than  all others and can
install cheaper and
install better in the system solution
that you can now bring these assets onto
the electricity market and they raise a
value for my customers that
others cannot offer because, for example, in
Sweden today,
our customers are now  They get an electricity tariff and
pay 0 cents per kilowatt hour
because we not only optimize these systems
on the electricity market but also
carry out network services, which
means if the network
is not stable in terms of frequency, our
systems are used to stabilize the network frequency,
which is a pure
infrastructure service  Is there
passive income and what does it lead to
that my hardware offering suddenly
has a much better ROI and a
much better arization time
than all of my competitors, which
means we're really I'm there. It may
sound arrogant, but I'm there, we
're there  The first game wasn't so short-sighted
and we're doing
quite well now. Hardware and
the hardware business is reaching its
limits simply because that's
exactly how you analyze it. Then
you just have to move on and the next
point is that  virtual assembly
line that means that really in the morning
when the sun rises and it never sets for
us no matter on everyone on every
workstation of this assembly line which
is completely digitalized which is
completely optimized and don't forget the
relevant competition for us is not
npal the relevant one  Competition for us
is all the electricians and heating engineers in the
world and that's the market we
want to get into. Why, I mean, we
've already
talked about internationalization. You've already
somehow mentioned Sweden and
Holland and Spain, but I
've read you are too  In Australia,
I was at least relatively
buff, okay, now they're getting really
crazy, now somehow straight
to Australia, so why Australia, too, that's also
the feedback we've
gotten several times that people say
you're completely crazy now, but that's all that's
missing  Hawaii yes and then
my answer is Australia is the
pioneer market for solar the most important
solar markets in the western world are
Germany in Europe now more and
more are being added Nordic Spain and even
follow markets so the European Union
then in within the USA is
California and Texas are the
most important markets and then comes
Australia because of the regulation because of
the regulation because there are
liberalized electricity markets and then
comes Australia Australia is
one of the oldest solar markets and we
are there too. In the end we also follow the
big brands that we
work with  and now back to the topic of
procurement power, if you are a national
hero you will never get
into a position with the suppliers
that you have so much volume that you
can tell them what you would like,
but we are talking about Chinese manufacturers,
we are talking about Chinese manufacturers
but we also work with
Solar Edge, which is Israel or with nface, which
is Silicon Valley based nastc 100
company, which is microin, you have to Hal
at some point you have to get into a situation
where you start running and [ __ ] now
comes really naturally,
of course, you're number one
Being in Holland or being number one
in Germany or being number one
in Sweden or being number one
in Spain is not worth as much
as being number 3 in all of
these markets um and that's the point
We want to be the top of the develop
world, we want to be among the top three
buyers to say to us, first of all,
better listen, dear
supplier, a bit at ktinental or
at Bosch, you just come in there
and if you have no idea Toyota
or Volkswagen  then you just have
more purchasing power then you go
in and say I would like it to be integrated like this for
my customers, please,
the interface is running, by the way, you are
slave and we are master and
you can only do that if you are in all the
relevant markets  At the same time,
you have a relatively large purchase, which is why
Australia is totally logical for us
because there is Tesla, there is nface, there is
Solar Edge, there is a very mature brand,
you also have the same situation in the
electricity market, which is super volatile because they
already have extremely high solar outputs,
that's fine  So, as if you were
looking at it from the outside, it
may be a bit us, but it
actually makes total sense to us
if you're just to give the listeners a
feeling if you're now thinking, man, what
's the end game, what can
a company like that do?  one day it will be worth it,
I mean, if that's
really what you're
describing, top 3 say allar energy
at least B2C sector
supplier in the western world, what are you
then so you're like a 100
billion company or what you are then
no but I think so  Well,
I don't even know if I'm talking about you,
so you have to say for yourself that they
manufacture microinverters that don't
have customer access, that don't
consolidate it, that don't have a brand, that are still
worth 20 billion and have a sales multiple.
Day is still at 78  yes that means
the one I would say we have so
in the base cas
[music]
scenario we will remain an aggregator in the
picture
incenario we can prove in some markets
that like Amazon we end up
having a vertical logistics integration
planning integration that is better
than  the others that means
you activate an Amazon like
rating also because in the area where you
don't ship books but where you
really talk about batteries and heat pumps,
these are big warning bodies, that's
automotive like no, if we can
do that the rating will also
increase significantly  If you then
manage to standardize a marketplace
that also has
a unique position, I would say, so that
everyone wants in there, we now have the first
manufacturers who want to give us money
for compatibility, which means we
have the first manufacturers who say
please, especially Werme pump manufacturers
They say we come now so often
customers and customers ask us whether the hubby
is compatible then they come and
want to pay us for our development services
just so that they are part of the
marketplace we can't do that yet
because we are too small we are
not there yet but  If we
reach this point, that the marketplace
itself, the marketplace for either
buying or selling electricity,
would become really dominant, um, then, um,
that's the sky the limit and I
would also say so that it doesn't
sound too cocky  is
the only business case that you
can build from Europe that
could be worth a trillion yes but not so
honestly no so not not because we
do it too, others do it too, not because we
are so cool or so intelligent but
that is the point of everyone  other game
AI um is decided in the USA or in China
or maybe
Israel somehow as a
niche market um or no matter what now
batteries or electric vehicles
the Chinese and the Americans who
play the game we can only
look at what we  In between, there is
a market where it is different and that
is the electrification of
buildings in mass and scale. There is no
developed market that has more removable
share that is more specifically designed for what
we do, which is the only
reason why Tesla  or or even sunrine
from California has not been dominated for a long time,
the Americans
simply neither have a liberalized
electricity market nor do they have the
penetration of renewable energy, that is,
the only absolute giga mega trend that
exists that
can be decided from Europe is also for a
global game  what we do
and I think that's really
cool because it doesn't matter what you
do now as Ai boys and girls, of course,
or somehow as a rocket, not
as a rocket as a sama but as a real
rocket developer or something like that in the end
you always look at the USA or China,
you can still
be bought or you will be
incubated somewhere but that is a case that can be
built from here and the volume
is yes, that is again around the the
the valuation potential is the
The entire energy supply for
electrified mobility,
before oil and gas, that was the entire valuation that
you had in the heating sector, wiesman, and
poderus, all tradespeople, across all
markets, that is the entire
heating sector, the heating sector and the
entire electricity sector, and that cumulatively
is the valuation potential that we are
addressing  But today you largely deal
with components
that also come from China,
so I mean it's
still somehow, let's say at
least part of it is a
down-to-earth business, so you have
a brand but you buy in parts
at least components from China
sells them more expensively let's go through the
components on each level
ne So in the area of ​​heat
we work with them there are Japanese and
with Stiebel that is Stiebelon from
Hildesheim is a German supplier
the production is predominantly in Europe we
respect  We see more of a cyber
security risk for all of these systems,
so it's not a geopolitical risk for you,
but China is
always a geopolitical risk for all industries,
but we've made sure since the founding
that we minimize this, which
means, for example, in the heating sector
that minimizes so we are not we do
n't work with Chinese yes there then
you can look in the inverter
energy storage area nface Solar Edge
Sonnen Sonnen German Solar Israeli
and NF are Americans too, of
course they have components in their supply chain
but there too we are primarily concerned
The AP integration is about the software
integration. The much greater risk for
us, in addition to the supply chains, if China
were to stop delivering is
that the Chinese at Huawei or
other brands they control
simply switch off the electronics and
a virus will hit them  If the
solar system doesn't work anymore then the
whole critical infrastructure does
n't work, we don't want that and that's why we've
always
decided not to have Schiner brands when it comes to electronics.
We have one exception, that's sangro,
but that's really the only one from
NME that we have  and
compared to others, we've already positioned ourselves
pretty well when it comes to decoupling. When it comes to
the production
of modules, we can't
avoid China. You've also
heard that in the energiezone podcast. There's
a lot of discussion about it now
I'll just say the
solar modules, the
value chain for this cannot be beaten at the moment,
um, it's located in
China and we have them made to order
like Apple does. With the
iPhone we make one ready to order
and the Frauenhoferintitut does the testing
but we bring it  the basic materials from
Europe come in, that means poli can agree, would
you like a different political
orientation, that this is also
a different
topic of politics, how did you
notice fismann's move, that they
were now also active somewhere in the wider environment and now  have said
that it's now getting too intense, the pressure is
too big, we have to join a larger
structure and then we sold parts of your
business, your traditional business,
I think it was great
timing, so here again
head of yes review timing super good
I also believe that  it's
again that you h when we talk about valuation,
what have they
paid for? In the end,
market access has also been paid for. You have to
imagine that if you
are now heat pump savvy, the problem is to
get into the European market
These are wholesalers, specialist dealers,
among them are electrical tradesmen or
even heating trades, they
have a high level, it's super
fragmented, you can't
just enter the market with large
quantities, yes, that means the
heat pump manufacturers who have now
increased their heat pump capacities have to
find a direct
market channel  somehow secure it and I
think that
FES recognized this very well that,
firstly, a
Scandinavian manufacturer also had very
high prices for, um, access
to the end customer channel, that is, they
also bought installers, for example, and I
think that FES did that  has recognized very well
that there is this pressure among the
large manufacturers, which are platform
manufacturers in the end who want to set up a large
water pump platform, who
need scaling, who need
throughput, but are encountering a
nasty market where 80% of the business
goes through small craft businesses that produce
50 water pumps a year  and where a
60-year-old decision-maker says I
've always done it before and I
can't think of anything else. Yes, that's
very, very difficult for them and that's why
I would say I don't know
what Fiesman himself or what Max
Fiesmann was thinking
I don't know that with his father, but
I think you can say that it
was probably the best time in decades to
make this sale and,
in my opinion, the value for the buyer is
not so much in the brand and market access
in the IP like vi how many
heat pumps have you actually
already sold or installed now via
Ex a little bit
that back to exactly now to
get back to the
real regulation where we are, I
think that too  Really okay, so we
only installed 500 heat pumps in Germany last year, um so
let's compare, npar did 1000,
and I would still say that we
are both still one of the largest companies in this area,
but it also shows how much progress
is possible  is 5 of course W you
think so, it's a fart no exactly absolutely absolutely
no with all the press and
all the
news that you can read then
someone who is currently
actively going full throttle says 500 pieces have
become
that roof I would have GT now  okay uh yes
but we have no you have to think about it we
have heating companies that are applying to
become part of the group with which
we are going into negotiations and they
say yes how we also ask how we
did you do yes 18 or so you can
Yes, don't forget last year there was
also a compression due to the heating law.
No
heat pump was triggered at all. No,
that means you only
got the funding packages in January. That
means, to be fair, you have to
discount that, um, due to the
uncertainty  In the funding area,
a lot of people haven't pulled the trigger.
How are you satisfied with our
federal government? I
think it's very difficult, so I
'm still someone who I
think I'm still a cool
guy, I think he wants to too  A lot of
things that are right, um, I still find it
difficult that the Greens
always believe that you have to intervene in
the market. Well, I
think the heat pump year 23 would have
been better if they had simply
done nothing at all because the technology is
there. There is simply no
trust in the technology  um but otherwise
I think it's just a crapshoot for them and also
for the traffic lights because
everything that could have gone wrong just went
wrong and they have to
bear the responsibility for it, who
else is responsible for it but I
really feel a bit sorry for that sometimes because
From our point of view, they have
set up many things correctly, but we are now communicating
more and more clearly in the direction of
politics and say please, please,
if anyone is listening now, yes, stop
with these market interventions, I'll give you
an example of microchips in Europe. There are
many billions in
production here  but no one comes up
with the idea of ​​telling people in the business
that there are fewer taxes or there
is some kind of subsidy program so that you
can buy products with a European
microchip. Um, the renewables have
always had these market interventions and
we wish there were. The KW
subsidy program is totally in  the pants
went 10,000 € for high earners that
was immediately sold out um for solar and
electricity storage um many many people do
n't invest in you are
actually educated to wait for the next subsidy
that is expensive and that also makes it
more difficult to build a sustainable market
that is what I think  The biggest
wish we have for politicians and
no, they have already set the framework
well, higher CO2 prices are fair, which keep
going up step by step,
but otherwise the framework that is there now,
maybe
doing nothing for two years wouldn't be the case at all  bad okay okay,
um, are you actually following the
unusual players that are now entering the
market? I've seen that now,
the colleagues who
made these unicorn condoms so that they
were also very successful were
here on the podcast years ago and they're
making them now too  Unicorn energy and you
can now, as an
apartment owner, put
a solar panel on your balcony, so to
speak, and then you can
somehow participate in the whole game,
is that nonsense or there are
several players who are now trying to do that,
really  Developing balconies
for this is what you're looking at, so we
're often asked about it by
customers who are basically
thinking about it, you can start like this and
also by investors what we
think about it,
that there are a few very
fundamental problems  One is
when you align a module with the sun,
a solar module, then
you try to put it on the roof so
that it is at an angle, for
example more like a table, because then
this naturally catches the electricity
better, so the light becomes  yes
captured that means you would
always build a module slightly inclined but
more like a table um and you
will never come up with the idea of
just hanging it vertically somewhere
because if you just
hang it somewhere you already have 60
70% of it  Energy is gone, of course,
and then the fact that these
modules are usually monoperk modules
means that it is often
very, they have to be lighter because if
they are very heavy, a real
module also weighs a few  Kilos more,
that means they have a low
guarantee and a lower
performance anyway and then hang vertically in
other words the kilowatt hour that
I produce with it is always more
expensive, significantly more expensive, twice to three times as
expensive as that of a roof system
if I say now I can  but I don't
have a roof system and it's
very, very important to me that I
have a solar system on my balcony, then
I think that's okay then you can
do it economically,
the kilowatt hour from the grid is probably still
cheaper, so it does
n't make that much economic sense
and it's a bit hyped up
then there are few guarantees it will be
like that Plug and Play is off my S is
also dangerous if you put it on wrong
and then it falls down afterwards
and somehow upside down and
it will happen so you can
probably do it  With the goods co-opening that is
possible then you can no longer
afford that the professional craftsman is no, that's
exactly it, it's plug and play,
you do it yourself at home but the joke
is still economical business mod ge
no different, yes but the joke is
e.g. the kilowatt peak is a
unit of performance in which
prices are also measured and a solar system from
us costs
less per kilowatt PE than
a balcony solar system if you only use the solar system
There
are electricians there because you
just notice that even if you
buy a 500 watt module for €1000,
it's usually 2 250s and
you attach them to it then you've only
got half a kW for €1000  You can get
a whole kW for us from us,
yes, that means it really doesn't make much
sense and it will be a
lot
You get a module that
has good performance and a good guarantee,
not in a hardware store somewhere else, but you
have to do a little
research and then you also see that
it might not be a tree directly
above it and that you don't
hang it vertically on a balcony, but instead
E.g. at the bottom somehow because you
are skilled in craftsmanship you can
create a slight slope so that the
light hangs better then it can
have a higher yield at some point
but I would say for the vast
majority of people who are now thinking about it
or as a fence that somehow  It
's not obstructed, so where you have free sun
on it, the south fence and there are no
trees in front of it and but in the end
you need a house to
be able to really play with you with us
You either have to
have a heater and then we can
also install a heat pump without you
having a solar system because then
we connect you to the
electricity market or you have a suitable
roof then you get a solar system or you
need a wall box and or a
power storage system  You can also do this on your own,
decoupled. If you want one of these
four units, you can get
it from us. Whatever you need. For
most of them, yes, then on the reg there is a house, yes, or
it is. We have a lot of
small businesses now, but also
farms, so as a rule  It's like it's
bigger to go for you
ma man somehow but we have
so we have now founded a commercial unit
because we have
such good coverage with 40 locations in Germany
that we notice that
owners in particular come with several
have properties and they say I
actually need a partner who will renovate
my entire property for the next few years
and because
we offer heat pumps plus solar systems with
energy saving and smart meters and
energy supply from a single source, there are
now more of them,
but they are typical landlords  They
just somehow
have small
commercial properties, residential
properties, have you read the book,
I thought it would be
surprising if that somehow
fit in, because the culture
you have is a bit
comparable to Tesla culture  I only think
in one area that we
are really very performance-oriented and
also very much we have a breaking point, which
means we try to have everyone have
a breaking point every six months,
something that they deliver for the company
if we don't manage it, i.e.
qualitatively  really
brings a step in development and if we do
n't manage to achieve it,
we just remain at a bit of a standstill in terms of quality,
so we don't make the next
evolutionary leap and these breaking
points are defined very clearly
so that you know exactly what you're
delivering, make it or break it  It is
essential that there are several breaking
points that contribute to each other, so they
are ok, you can also call that
and there are wiry systems that are also ok in the end,
ok KPI but above all also
sensitization to what does your
breaking point actually mean, your Oka for yours
for the others  Areas and for the
master plan that we have and then
of course we build up responsibility there
and also a little bit of
pressure and we do that
like at Tesla, that we are keen
on performance and that we
work hard and a lot and  can also show
that we do it ourselves, including the
founders, but and I think that's
the point where we're different is that we
have, I would still
say that
I would still
like to hang out with our top leadership in my private life  These are people
where you
can be 8 hours late at the airport and you
still like to spend time with them
because you trust each other and that
level of trust that I felt was
totally missing at Tesla and I think that's
already seen enough for  What
you are doing, I mean, clearly we
now have, on the one hand, the
small number of
heat pumps installed so far, on the other hand, the big
vision and so very far-fetched, so in my opinion, yes,
he has to execute everything,
but yes, there is one  German
company that is just trying it out and is
really attacking and you have
described so many topics, there are
not so many topics where you
can build something from Germany that
still plays a role on the world market and I think that is really true,
maybe there is  a few more but so
many so there aren't that many um
you feel like that in Germany you're already so if now
somehow
sufficiently noticed in the
broad masses or the feeling that there
are still far too many people who
say 1.5 what  what is that supposed to
be, what are they doing, it's not
Ms. Neubauer's thing or something like that, I don't know, so
where are you, but the
honest answer is, um, I'm
totally
bipolar and I think I'm also like
I have this typical one  Founder's disorder
that on the one hand it's never enough for you and on
the other hand it's way
too much at the same time, so I'm
already being spoken to on the street and
we're getting really cool, so
I have people who just tap me on
the shoulder and then show them their cell phone
because they
have the 1.5° sticker on the back of their cell phone and say so
cool, or while jogging
some people who
have applied say age is cool. I was
recently at a private
birthday party and there were three people there
tischpr I didn't know anyone yet,
was in Berlin in the soohaus, met there,
said they
applied to us and did
n't get the place, yes and that
and that were cool people and
in that respect I would say in certain
moments they were  totally and in others then
you leave your bubble and come into
other areas and um of course
you also have exactly what you describe it
we are in we are on from certain
points of view mega far and from
other points of view we are a
fart of the landscape and feel that  Me
too, I have this bipolarity
and this feeling that we are actually
really cool but on the other hand,
we are still at the beginning and the
feeling of the imposter syndrome and so on, that
is there, both of which are always there, you
think you are somehow  a braggart
or of course, of course, just when we
had the first podcast, of course,
that was our plan that I told you,
but did
I know that it
would come?
Install a heat pump,
no, and somehow install a wallbox yourself,
not either, so that
means you're now also
looking for engineers. Engineers are
mainly
electricians, but I think it's crazy that
they do all of the things themselves, so
I'm just wondering  so zest ago I would
say that's how you imagine it I'm
sure that il mas can't
install a powerwall that you I would
bet but he could
probably know very well so he
understands how it works or he could
but I hope so  that I
understand that the products and also the
differentiation deal with a lot
or walk around in the factory hall and
say hey guys, why don't we do it
differently, that's a
difference, so you can't
go there and say guys, somehow just leave
it alone  Install it differently, let's do something like
that, somehow
leave out particles or something like that, then it will be cheaper
that that doesn't work, that's okay, that's okay, that's okay,
but I think it's going to be too far, so you
can you can add a cost for everything
and  You go to a company and say
okay, you don't know anything about this company,
you don't know anything about the
people, you know nothing about the
technology and then you
just sit down and say what is the cost
of installation and then you start saying
that nobody knows anything  The cost of
installation is then you first have to
assign which personnel costs are
actually charged and how where are
they booked in and then you start to
say within this cost of what are
the points that are really relevant
where where and then
I'm interested in that  Then I also say you have two or
three points where we
cost a lot and I want to
understand that in detail from a procedural point of view. I'll go
deep into it, but I
still had no idea beforehand. I think
one of the points that freed me
is me  I'm self-taught and
I'm still not a
trained electrician and I don't have
the means or
the hands to do it,
but I do
n't have any fear of contact at all
back involved
artificial dead we also
designed that ourselves yes,
I think you have to understand as an
entrepreneur or as a C level or
as a leader what
your business is and you also have to
have an opinion and a feeling for it like
the basics  principles, whether they are
technical, whether they are people, whether they
are KPIs, it doesn't matter what
it is, you have to understand it, if it is
essential and I have that claim, it
still doesn't mean that I
could connect Wallbox, okay, everything is
clear, okay, now I have it  I asked everything
before and told myself you actually have to
leave earlier now I've probably
overdid it I hope it was still
worth it I thought it was a great conversation
Thank you very much
for the update
and yes in two years at the latest
again or maybe for the IPO or the
monster round I  I don't know,
we would like to accompany it
and here and there we have
contact in Hamburg anyway. I'll keep my fingers crossed for you and
yes, let's see
I think it was
a bit longer again, yes, but it
's a big story, it's a big
story. Hof, I hope it's us, we're okay,
thank you very much, all
right, ciao ciao
[music]
bye